quanti sono i the stories anzi
bentornati a grandissima richiesta un
nuovo video trova gli ingredienti slime
questa volta però dovrò trovare gli
ingredienti slime giganti nascosti dal
pagliaccio cattivo quindi mettetevi pure
comodi e prendete i pop corn
perché questa challenger sarà un po
paurosa un po applicate un bel mi piace
se volete vedere altri video con il
pagliaccio cattivo come sempre se questo
video raggiunge i 20 mila mi piace ci
sarà un secondo episodio lo scorso video
trova gli ingredienti slide nascosti dal
lupo cattivo
vi è piaciuto tantissimo e sta per
raggiungere i 20 mila mi piace quindi
fategli raggiungere i 20 mila mi piace e
il lupo tornerà andate a vederlo dopo
questo video sono 93 ancora di più
durante questo video ci sarà la parola
segreta del giorno se riuscite a
trovarla scrivetela subito nei commenti
di amo chi è il primo che riesce a
trovarla in quanti riescono a trovarla
quindi state attenti durante il video
perché sarà enasco pronti miss elementi
scomodi avete preso le patatine
iniziamo la nostra esplorazione e
ricerca dei nostri ingredienti ok
iniziamo a estrarre la stanza non ho
ancora visto il pagliaccio cattivo
quindi non so come sia né che aspetto
abbia e non so se lui come granny è
sordo non è sorto non treni in realtà è
cieca ma sente benissimo e per quello
che bisogna fare super silenzio come se
non so se questo pagliaccio è cieco
sordo voci vede male o si vede bene
ognuno ha una sorta di difetto
spero che lui non ci senta bene perché
il mio problema è sempre il rumore
soprattutto quando si ha un berlino
conti iniziano
questa stanza che come sapete sempre
quasi sempre d'acqua che iniziamo in
centro troviamo sempre qualcosa di
nascosto
quindi iniziamo subito e poi usciamo e
nelle altre stanze dove troviamo insomma
qualcosa pronti vediamo se proprio
qualcosa qua mi ricordo che c'era sempre
qualcosa qua in mezzo ai miei pupazzi
vediamo ok vediamo se c'è qualcosa qua
in mezzo ai pupazzi opera mini è caduta
ciao berlino ti stai trai andò a letto
figure che mi devi aiutare anche se hai
sonno come sempre deve interne trovare
gli ingredienti e così sbadiglia come
sempre
allora non mi sembra che quasi si sa
niente ma non ci credo pikachu
capitolati per tutti che cosa ha ficcato
in mano che il canino la paletta e
arancione quindi immagino che lo slime
di questa solenne sarà l'arancione in
genere così fo che appoggiamo l'acqua
[Musica]
era qui tantissimo non so perché non mi
ha rincorso però forse usa un altro ecco
è arrivato berlino con il giochino
rumorose grazie merlino e sono sicura
che riuscirò a vincere questa legge se
continui a usare questi giochini
rumorosi lo so che voi siete la steel
umano un posto deve farsi race berlino
ad allenatore e come faccio a vincere
questa challenge con berlino che pagassi
in giro come sempre ho fatto la rima
come l'altra volta non so perché non vi
abbia rincorso forse qualche qualche
potere diverso
non lo so devo comunque stare molto
attenti a non farmi prendere anche
perché non so quante vite o in questa
challenge forse solo un marino tu sai
quante video da berlino non lo fa
aspettando che gli tiro la pallina che
sono qua controlliamo se c'è qualcosa in
questa stanza anche perché il pagliaccio
non mi sembra che sia quindi
mi sembra di vedere niente
forse devo cambiare stanza sarà rimasto
ancora di il pagliaccio se c'è qualcosa
combattono feder.mot il colorante
gigante arancione quindi avendo pinato
si è ispirato proprio alla paletta ma
forse in quest'episodio tutti i pupazzi
reggeranno gli ingredienti insomma
oltremodo in colorati gigante berlino no
affatto la pallina nato avrà all favo
dino marino silvia
[Musica]
youtube
per fortuna sono ancora nel gioco quindi
fuggire che più di una possibilità è
viva e ho anche preso il colorante
gigante qui alla fine ho solo perso una
possibilità ho perso una vita il
problema è che non so quante altre meno
comunque inquietantissimo fissi ti
accorti non so se berlino il pagliaccio
che stanno facendo questo rumore
comunque vi siete accorti che berlino
stava cercando di salvarmi che è saltato
addosso gli affitti non so se sia marino
adesso spero che il paglia tu l'abbia
preso a controllare per ora appunto
libico si fa il colorante è la paletta
mi sono resa conto che in quella stanza
penso che non ci fossero molti altri
ingredienti quindi provo andare
nell'altra parte
a
[Musica]
l'avete visto
si stava sbrigando è un pagliaccio un po
quanto in quella stanza perché lui è lì
che stessa spicchiato negli occhi e vado
dalla parte opposta
chi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
non esco vedere attraverso quale se
ancora lì stava per prendere
camerino per fortuna ma ghiaccio sono
una scossa qua sotto
so come ho fatto a scappare prima
e ancora questo
a lui è andato proprio lì
e andato io non vivo
ma certamente
sono nell'altra stanza con trovato
d'accordo da gigante evviva
ora mi manca so che la soluzione perché
in tempi carbonato e farla nostra
e poi forse siamo riusciti a sconfiggere
il pagliaccio e questo da trasportare un
po pesante quindi forse è meglio se
l'apporto in camera e poi torna a
cercare qualcos'altro
ok andiamo
e andato tutto che ci sia pericolo
tra l'altro silvio dimenticando che ho
bisogno anche della ciotola in realtà
non posso farlo line senza aggiunto
quindi sono tre cose che devo ancora
trovare provato alla reti la vediamo se
trovo qualcosa mi ha preso di nuovo a
prestazione clienti
questo è importantissimo perché mi
mancano solo due cose su quante vite o
ancora forse non è più non posso
chiederlo a lui
ecco berlino fino fini 4 e merlino per
capire dove ritagliarci anzi devo non
nel senso devo evitare di andare
dovevamo berlino perché in genere
berlino è sempre 26 il pagliaccio ok
proviamo questa nuova strategica dove
c'è marino non devo andare
e forse riuscirò a prenderli proviamo
dove brino
caprino e sulla stanza è andato sul
letto
allora profondono andar lì che siamo
propriamente qui
sta facendo l'amore no niente altro in
questa stanza sicuramente dovrò tornare
nella camera da letto si faccia
annunciato una falla qui a berlino cosa
così non posso fare l'amore forse no
perché tu saresti capace di prenderla
meglio della punto in alto la maggiore
assoluto ma si fa che dino marino tenuto
la ciotola
ora mi manca serbo che manca sono
ritornato tipo detto
[Applauso]
marino
bisogna riuscita a prendere tutto sono
infatti cioè senza ce l'ha fatta
scappare i due che in quello di
carbonato devo tornare di là dove cielo
il pagliaccio no non voglio parlare le
abbiamo ragazzi questo è l'ultimo sforzo
e poi penso che farcela fatto non mi
preme nuovamente perché fossero
oltretutto la prima ora facciamo servizi
e mina che fa per dire qualcosa
così un qualcosa che qualche ingrediente
fa poi c'è il bayern ci si liberino
[Musica]
dibenedetto bravissimo visto prima io
ero io
provare a rubare sta facendo un musical
prenderlo non credo
si era partiti merlini appositi che
riusciremo a bagnanti e non c'è ma non
so se la prima parte sono riuscita a
recuperare giugno che ci vuoi dire
qualcosa ho preso tutto che non solo
fare le slave ma adesso
ok ragazzi abbiamo tutti gli ingredienti
e non sento nessun rumore quindi forse
il pagliaccio è scomparso da qualche
parte non lo so anche se berlino e qui
non so perché non perdiamo tempo cromia
supercolla gigante quanto tempo ci
metterò ad attivarlo
forse è meglio se non lo faccio proprio
gigante altrimenti ci metterò un sacco
ad attivarlo pratico comunque farlo un
po più grande
ok penso che così può bastare mi è
caduto un po di collo e sud
ciao altrimenti case mettiamo subito il
colorante gigante quindi ne metterò
certo possiamo bellissimo slam arancione
altissimo questo colore
[Musica]
ha sentito si stanno vicino
i'm briga di che c'è qualcosa tanto
tempo ad attivare gli slide paninari
ciao ti fa male il braccio rate ragazzi
e quasi uscito è ancora un pochino pc
cose ma guardate certissimo è
grandissimo e bellissimo questo slime on
call of pain guardate e super lucido e
the tough è riuscito a super grand e
come la colla ha ferito e pisa
ce l'ho fatta peccato che non so dove
sia sbagliato altrimenti proverei
insomma a sconfiggerlo in qualche modo
ma lo slime comunque pronto so che devo
fare adesso spero che si faccia vivo
forse può andare a trovarlo in back di
goetze
mi sono spaventata a morte è riuscito
voi dall'armadio ma tanto noi avevamo
già nello tra slime pronta quindi avevo
vinto anche questa challenge lasciate un
bel mi piaccio se volete vedere altre
challenge blind trova gli ingredienti
slime o con il pagliaccio e ora vi
lascio qua quattro case linee su cui ti
caro per vedere i nostri altri in slide
per vedere i nostri altri video cliccate
su quella che preferite
ciao
[Musica]